knalleffekt in einem gerichtsgebäude in
brooklyn new york kelly der berühmte
orchester wurde soeben schuldig
gesprochen im sexprozess des jahres hier
in new york kelly dem r b superstar war
vorgeworfen worden
minderjährige mädchen sexuell
missbraucht zu haben es wurde ihm auch
vorgeworfen sie über staatsgrenzen
hinweg zu transportiert zu haben sie
sexuell ausgebeutet und bedroht zu haben
insgesamt wie gesagt neuen anklagepunkte
in allen hieß es gilt die jury also die
geschworenen waren sich hier einig ein
wirkliches drama vor gericht und brennen
im gerichtssaal saß der angeklagte r
kelly mit stoischer gefasster männer
sein kopf war leicht nach unten gesenkt
nur ab und wann schloss er die augen es
gab allerdings kein kopf schütteln wie
man es früher im prozess gesehen hat
auch keller verließ den gerichtssaal es
wurden im draußen an handschellen
angelegt es geht zurück in die
untersuchungshaft das strafausmaß wird
festgelegt anfang mai am 4 von der
richterin bei einem weiteren speziellen
hearing daneben wird klargestellt wie
lange kelly für seine verbrechen ins
gefängnis muss es war ein wirklich am
mammut prozess hier in brooklyn die
staatsanwaltschaft hat 45 zeugen und
zeugen hier aufgefahren die schaurige
details zu verraten haben über die
übergriffe durch kelly es gab hier
wirklich grauenhafter einzelheiten die
die jury zu hören bekamen wie auch die
weltöffentlichkeit darunter eben die
methode erkenne wie diese frauen
angelockt wurden wie sie dann bedroht
wurden dass sie nicht sagen wie sie auch
betrogen wurden und ausgebeutet wurden
die appelle immer wieder auch
videos angefertigt hat über während den
sechs akten die als erpressung dienen
sollten all das wurde hier ausgerollt
für die verteidigung blieb dann nur mehr
wenig zu retten eigentlich sie hatten
nur fünf zeugen ausgesagt die
verteidigung insgesamt hat hier keinen
besonders solide präsentation
abgeliefert aber wahrscheinlich hätte
das auch am ende nichts genützt zu
überwältigend zu eindeutig waren die
ganzen beweise gegen kelly deshalb ist
die jury die geschworenen sind zu einem
urteil in nur neun stunden beratungen
gekommen das ganze hier in brooklyn war
natürlich auch ein riesiges
medientheater medienzirkus der man viele
sagen hier der promi prozess des jahres
und der ist eben mit diesem knalleffekt
einer serie an kritisch prüfen zu ende
gegangen
[Musik]